Consider the overwhelming success as a
Patreon account the money raised by
rebel.
What will you be doing with the
contributions?
Well,
that's great.
Alright,
so I've got a couple of things to say
about that.
So the first one is,
you know,
I would say a number of people have been
attempt and not an overwhelming number,
but a number of people have been
attempting to take me to task for the
fact that my Patreon support has been,
let's call it overwhelmingly successful.
And so I'll tell you how I formulate my
response to that.
The first is I'm generating almost all
of my content and making it completely
publicly accessible so it's free,
right?
And,
and so that way I'm bringing,
I think awareness of psychological
issues to a very large number of people.
And so far at the moment my view count
on Youtube is up to $30 million and I
did a little bit of calculations last
week to try to figure out what the total
view count was,
um,
for,
for the cuts of my lectures that have
been appearing on Youtube.
And then the political material as well.
And I think it's upward of $50 million
and so I'm making psychological and
political content available to $50
million people.
And so,
you know,
that seems like a reasonable thing to do
now.
People who don't agree with what I'm
saying might differ,
but I think that could be separated from
the educational content as well.
So,
and then with regards to the Patriot on
subscribers,
every single person who's doing that is
doing it entirely voluntarily.
And I also set up that Patriot on
account long before any of this
political material emerged.
So.
And my sense with the patron viewers,
and you guys can clue me in if I'm wrong
about this,
is that there's two things happening.
One is it enables people who are not
very happy about the current political
situation in the west to to,
to contribute to something that might be
at least to some degree attempting to
stem the tide of such things as toxic
political correctness and second,
that it enables people to support my
endeavors,
to bring general education to a wider
audience.
And that seems like a good deal for
everyone.
And,
you know,
you might say,
well,
it's a particularly good deal for me and
I'm certainly not complaining about
what's happening,
but I would also point out that it
hasn't exactly been a straightforward
thing.
And so,
um,
so I guess if anyone else wants to try
it,
they're more than welcome to.
Now having said that,
um,
I would also say that the real issue
here,
and I think this is the fact that this
isn't self evident,
is also a commentary on the toxicity of
our culture at the moment,
is that it actually isn't the issue.
The issue isn't really how much money
you have.
I think that that's a resentful and at
relatively vicious way of judging
someone else.
I think the issue is what you do with
the money when you have it.
And you know,
I'm,
I'm not a particularly hedonistic person
and I'm not 25 years old,
you know,
I'm 55 years old and I'm going to be a
grandfather and a couple of months,
you know,
thank God for that.
Um,
and what I want to do with that money is
to do the best things I can possibly
think of to do with it.
And one of the things I'm thinking
about,
I started this biblical series and a lot
of that's helped thankful thanks to you
guys on Patrion because that enabled me
to generate the capital that was
necessary to rent the theater because
for 12 lectures that was a $60,000
investment about that,
something like that.
And then another $8,000
for the,
for the camera work.
And that had to be basically dealt with
upfront.
So it was a reasonable financial risks.
Now I've been crazily fortunate in that
theater tickets have also sold out,
so it looks like the biblical series
will pay for itself with some extra
leftover.
And so,
you know,
I'm pretty happy about that because that
gives me some more working capital.
And then you might say,
well what am I going to do with the
capital?
Well,
I'm going to continue doing the sorts of
things that I'm already doing.
I want to do a series on the hundred
greatest books of the western Canon.
For example.
I want to move genuine humanities
education out of the universities where
it isn't being taught anyways as far as
I can tell online where people can
access it freely.
I'm talking to a wide variety of people
right now about trying to do that in a
more formal sense so that the
possibility for widespread university
education can be universally accessible
and one of the things we're trying to
crack is the problem of how to teach
people to write.
Because that's a real troublesome thing.
And by the way,
you know you guys,
if you go onto my website,
Jordan Peterson.com
and you go into courses and you go into
psychology for 30.
If you look carefully there,
you'll see that there's an essay rubric
that tells people how to write and
actually that's become quite popular.
And so if you're interested in how to
learn to write,
I've written something about that
already and we're going to make a piece
of software that's going to help people
learn to write.
And so I've got plans for how to make
writing education broadly accessible to
people,
so I would like to make humanities
education of the highest order broadly
accessible to people and I also want to
teach them how to write and I'm going to
try to crack the online university
accreditation problem.
And so part of the money that,
or a substantial proportion of the money
that is being donated to me,
let's say,
or is being offered to me by my monthly
supporters.
So that's all of you people is going to
be going to projects exactly like that.
And the reason for that is that,
what the hell else would I do with the
money?
You know,
I mean,
to me money is a tool.
It's not,
it's not the means whereby you develop a
luxurious lifestyle and spend your time
burning yourself half to death in the
sun and the Caribbean snorting cocaine
and chasing hookers,
you know,
it's just,
that's just not in the cards for me.
Um,
and,
and so I want to devote it towards the
sorts of things that I've already been
pursuing except on a broader scale.
And so,
you know,
and I think people like Elan Musk to,
not that I'm comparing myself to Elon
Musk,
but I mean he has plenty of money and I
mean you really,
somebody's got to have the damn money.
It might as well be people who have the
kind of vision that people like he does
have because maybe they'll do something
good for the world.
I mean I hope his gigafactories produce
batteries like mad so that we can start
to make alternative energy sources
economically viable and maybe reduce our
dependence on oil and maybe get
ourselves out from underneath the thumb
of the Saudi Arab.
So that would be a good thing.
So the monetary issue,
it's,
it's quite interesting.
It's like it is not that you have the
money,
it's what you do with it.
And so anyways,
those are,
some of them might plants and that isn't
all of them because I'm going to come up
with a bunch more plans and I'm going to
try to implement them as rapidly as I
possibly can.
I've put my clinical practice on hiatus
for the next three months so that I have
a chance to think and I've requested
that the university advanced my
sabbatical by one year,
so I should have about a year to think
about what I should be doing with
youtube and how I can be promoting broad
public education of the highest quality
and that's a really fun problem to solve
and the fact that I'm being supported by
all of you people on Patrion makes the
probability that avail to all be able to
devote my time to that much higher.
So,
so that's what I'm going to do with it.
I'm going to do the best things I can
possibly think of to do with it.
And uh,
hopefully that'll work.
And so far it seems to be going well.
So,
um,
yeah,
I mean I've been taking them back quite
a bit by the.
I mean it's not surprising that the
people who've been trying to take me
down,
let's say are squawking and bitching
because I happened to be a generating a
fairly reasonable income from this.
Although I don't think about it as an
income,
as I already said,
I think about it as a,
as a toolkit for pursuing more
interesting things.
It's like if that's the best they can do
with regards to continuing to tarnish my
name,
well then let them,
let them go right ahead about that and I
think the proof is in the outcome and
the biblical series and that's a direct
consequence of the Patriot and support
that seems to be going like mad.
I think you know,
about 500,000
people have watched the videos so far
with another who knows,
tens of thousands of people listening to
the podcasts and that's just a bloody
miracle that,
that many people would be interested in
what I consider the fundamental
foundation for any true humanities
education.
So great.
We'll build from there.
And so that's,
that's what I'm gonna do with the money.
So.
And if people don't like that,
then they don't have to donate or they
don't have to subscribe.
It's hardly like it's mandatory.